am freitag besucht
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
die angelobung von rekruten der garde in
weißenkirchen in niederösterreich in
ihrer ansprache erinnerte an alte
rekruten an die wichtigkeit ihres
einsatzes in diesen zeiten sie sind die
basis in wahrheit des bundesheeres denn
ohne sie würde es würde es kein
bundesheer geben keine berufssoldaten
geben keine miliz geben
mein vaterland
die republik österreich
und seit volk zu schützen und
mit der waffe zu verteidigen
sie haben eine entscheidung getroffen
unsere republik zu dienen die werte
demokratie menschenrechte zu verteidigen
das bundesheer muss ja eines seien die
sicherheit garantiere eine versicherung
für uns österreicherinnen und
österreicher die hoffentlich wie
eingelöst werden muss aber wir müssen
vorbereitet sein auf alles
der republik österreich und
dem österreichischen volk
ich bin stolz auf sie ich danke ihnen
für diese entscheidung für die
sicherheit unserer republik für die
sicherheit von uns ein
[Musik]